[Music]
a man
walks into a friend's into friend's
steakhouse in a place called uh clanton
okay it's in alabama hmm
sounds like plant oh spoke
like oh alabama yeah i mean
i want to drink clamton like clan town
oh
damn he figured it out let's put it on
clientele
[Laughter]
do the clapton dance
not for that face it wouldn't even be
funny to me
it wouldn't be funny to me i'm gonna
lose a loose situation damn clan damn
but that was pretty good though whatever
i don't even know what he did he looked
like you at the clan town jamboree
so jason todd walks into this
into this place where his band was
playing one final set uh a summer three
years ago
tanya anderson his wife stood outside in
the parking lot drunk demanding to drive
herself home he told her you cannot
drive
and i will take you shortly after i pay
for my tab
uh he's like i'm not mad at you and
she's like [ __ ] you i'll walk home right
and then he didn't think she was gonna
walk home um she didn't say [ __ ] you she
said fine uh
[Laughter]
she began walking
and then um
she
got struck and killed by an oncoming
vehicle
that was him no okay the irony would
have been crazy because he's all like no
you can't be walking low and then he
comes and he drunk drives drunk and he
hits her well the irony is that
the man stopped his wife from driving
drunk and then she got killed
anyways oh
by another drunk driver it doesn't say
by a drunk driver maybe she was a drunk
walker and she was walking in the middle
of the road
so he shouldn't even let her walk
yeah so
um but
in in an unusual turn local police opted
to charge the husband with manslaughter
for the death of her why his crime was
throwing his wife's keys across the road
sending her on a precarious deadly
search
and he has repeatedly denied throwing
her keys there's no evidence that he
actually did that and he was too drunk
to remember anyway he was way too [ __ ]
up it says it's remembered how did they
even come to that like how'd they find
out about the keith maybe someone at the
bar was like i saw him
i saw him well i saw him i saw him
she [ __ ] threw that [ __ ] thing i
got that case
oh it wasn't the mask
it was just the joke yeah it was accent
it was excellent uh so now the husband's
suing uh the police officer who's whose
investigation led to the charge counter
suit and he's also suing the restaurant
and the driver in state court for his
wife's death not a suing going around
huh yeah uh that's exactly right awesome
i see the [ __ ] out everybody as well
yeah imagine like how [ __ ]
shitty that situation is and then people
were like oh it's your fault
you're getting charged for manslaughter
that's crazy yeah so it was around
midnight when a 2007 blue dodge charger
struck her and kept driving um anybody
gonna charge the the driver yeah they're
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah oh [ __ ] there's a
guy we're totally forgetting about here
well the guy was inside trying to take
care of his tab and he also told he also
because it was his band
he was like hey we're not going to play
our last set like like you know um i
just want to make sure i take care of my
wife right but he was still inside the
inside the bar
and then he didn't know that she had
left
and apparently she was outside with her
camera phone light on looking for
something in the road which is what
makes them allege that he threw the keys
maybe oh
it could have been anything could have
we don't know she could have been
looking for bugs or uh what about the
driver that killed her and drove off the
hit and run you mean yeah they threw
them on a parade
that charger was too sick man
it's got it's fine yeah yeah
where's the drunk driver in all of this
or just a driver yeah so the driver is
also being investigated right now right
big for manslaughter
but they but they want to charge
um the husband because of
what led to
her being in the middle of the road
being an enabler
charging the bar
this this uh this ex-girlfriend
who told her boy ex-boyfriend to go kill
himself
she's uh she's being charged with um
what is it like murder or something like
that i heard about that she's like
second degree she played guilty plead
guilty wow yeah originally she said not
and they do a documentary on that no
it's too recent really new i heard
another case on that was it was based on
documentary same kind of story
but it was like a little more dark than
just that i was like damn that's crazy
man like you could talk some [ __ ] it
didn't be charged for [ __ ] murder but
didn't she like work him like it was
like it was really yeah yeah it was it
was intense it wasn't your usual like
kill yourself it wasn't him saying he
was gonna do it and she was like well
then [ __ ] do it like she really
pushed it maybe you should do it oh she
was like convincing him she had like a
powerpoint she was the source of the
[ __ ] idea yeah like hey killing
yourself would solve a lot of this [ __ ]
right over time over time like he would
be like what do you want to eat well how
would you kill yourself it was like kind
of that [ __ ] like how do you bring that
kind of conversation up like hey have
you ever thought about offing yourself
just you know hypothetically like a
commercial you know
well when you say you're like that it's
so you're suffering from living
side effects include stress
[Laughter]
side effects or diarrhea
still
i'm bored
[ __ ] man is life getting boring
haven't died in a while all your friends
at jk roasting you too much
did i say that out loud i was just
supposed to think it yeah i can't get it
i don't get it that's not really
relatable to people at home
yeah you having problems a guy this good
looking come on now yeah i did this sex
however over here guy who [ __ ] a lot
gets his dick sucked no one has any
sympathy for that oh poor anthony gets
his [ __ ] sucked every night yeah oh
can't take a couple jokes from bart
dude i'm not the one steve steve's going
to roast them i'm mr nice guy when you
wear a hat that's like eight sizes too
small for your body it [ __ ] it's so
cute when you say stuff
joe should biden run again yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah
let's go biden
there it is
what is that character remember that guy
in the primaries
oh howard dean oh dave spell oh just
kept thinking [ __ ]
his cheer
howard dean
he never survived that no no that ruined
his whole [ __ ] that's crazy man how
did that how do you even scream like
that do anything wrong it was just like
so black he was just he was just
absolutely [ __ ] he had a red bull and
he was like let's go he was too he was
too hyped and everybody got embarrassed
for him discovered the most uncool sound
you could make
it's just such an unfortunate you could
have the sickest policies and no one
gives a [ __ ] yeah dude like hey you're
actually the yarra guy
yeah you want to give me free health
care yeah what about jared though who
was he running against he was running
against bush this was like 2000 oh
because that was like when john kerry
got the uh
yeah got the nomination that's what they
needed is like an exclamation consultant
to be like hey when you get excited this
is your sound
because they didn't have that [ __ ] no no
it went wild
campaign managers like don't do that
again in tennessee okay you're killing
us man with that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a
very vermont move because he was the
governor of vermont at the time oh sorry
maybe that's so yeah but that's a very
low populated state all the vermonters
were like [ __ ] yeah dude find some
representation
but then everyone was like yo this is
just whack as [ __ ] vermont's the size of
san jose you could drive through no
[ __ ] way you could go like this while
you're
you could be driving and then not off
you drove through vermont no but it is
pretty quick though like i went i went
up there to snowboard oh when you went
to maine dude yeah like from no vermont
new hampshire all those little [ __ ]
cheese size uh places
they're the size of cheese you know like
in under an hour or no about an hour
yeah not up and down but side to side
yeah yeah wow well so uh back to the
story
uh this [ __ ] if he gets charged
for manslaughter because the case is on
him that would suck but if he wins
everybody who [ __ ] charged them
should go to hell i mean anytime you
have a chance to sue the city for
something it's [ __ ] great i wish
going to hell was uh was an actual thing
you could win like like oh you wanna sue
me for my money i'm gonna sue you to go
to hell
and then like if you win they actually
have to go to hell yeah wow
that'll be sick dude seems like come on
[ __ ] it's time to go to hell like
what like throwing you like a volcano no
like they open up satan's door and then
you walk into the gates of hell
duh so the guy who hit her i don't think
volcanoes have hell guy who hit her is
blind in his right eye why is he driving
well so they found the guy yeah yeah so
he should have [ __ ] used this open
the the eye that worked he initially ran
from
he ran from the crime because he's blind
his right eye thought he hit a deer and
local authorities who examined his car
determined that he did in fact hit a
deer and they did not take samples from
the hood oh because he's like oh i had a
[ __ ] deer so then so it's not totally
the woman who's wearing dark clothing
who's standing in the middle of the road
who's intoxicated who gets hit by a car
by a guy who's [ __ ] blind in his
right eye
maybe there's a little bit of a case
about how
he's not guilty of throwing her keys in
the road right yeah like maybe he didn't
put her in the middle of the road when
she got hit maybe a guy who's [ __ ]
blinded plot twist to this [ __ ]
like a like an onion wow blind in his
right hand so lying on his right eye and
she was standing on the right side of
the road
so he hit
and he's like oh [ __ ] a deer and he
called the cops i think i hit a deer is
there a law about that yeah that dude's
chair should be swiftly [ __ ] this way
yeah
and then when the cops came they were
like it looks like a fish
he's just side eyeing about to drive if
you have if you don't have to i don't
think so
a lot of people only have one eye though
a glass a lot of them in the video
they fought for one-eyed rights
i think the sheriff was like um by the
by the looks of the sequence sparkle all
over the hood
this deer was fabulous
and it's not a human being it was a
closeted deer it was a gate year got it
so you know in that kind of state they
wanted to keep it quiet right so they're
like we're not gonna tell people we're
not gonna sorry bad habit we're not
gonna tell people that there's an
epidemic of gay deer yeah that's
embarrassing that's embarrassing i can't
wait and
these people were like excuse me
it's a genderless deer oh i see yeah and
these people were like
they're illegal immigrants
i got a question why do we even need to
be on the show josh just do the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you